so I don't know how many of you followed
the news and ethical machine-learning
but there was an article this week by a
publication called ProPublica and they
produce investigative journalism they
took a look at some ZIP codes in
Illinois and they found that certain zip
codes were paying more for the same car
insurance premiums so they were paying
more money even though all of the
different risks were the same and what
they found were these zip codes also
reflected racial biases and that black
neighborhoods were paying more than
white neighborhoods this is just one
example of the many ways that our
algorithms and models can possibly
reflect biases that we don't intend for
them to do so today we're going to talk
about creating fair models even when we
have an unjust world I don't know how
many fans we have of Black Mirror how
many people have seen black mayor and
how many people have seen this
particular episode excellent for those
of us that haven't a black mirror is a
science fiction kind of fantasy world
and it often talks about the horror
between technology and our lives this is
from season two and it's an episode
called news dive and in this world we
see Lacey here and she's the main
character in this world everybody is
based on ratings so essentially your
whole life is a metric other people rate
you when they interact with you it's
five stars or one star anything in
between and those ratings help determine
where you can live where you can work
what you can do and who you interact
with in the episode we have Chester here
he and his partner broke up and his
partner convinced everybody to downvote
him eventually his rating gets so low he
cannot go to work anymore and this is
kind of of course a very dystopian
picture and you might be like Katherine
what does this have to do with anything
but when we think about all the ways
that we connect we follow and we like
different things in our world and the
signals that that sends the
rhythms but then further recommend
things to us that further tell us who we
should connect with then we are actually
making these statements and these
statements may or may not affect not
only what we see and who we can connect
with but also affect the other people on
the receiving end so just like Chester
could not get in the door where are the
doors in our society and by this I don't
mean physical doors
I mean metaphorical or symbolic doors
one such example could be our career
path so job applications often have
algorithms behind them or some sort of
metric that you must meet to move
forward
LinkedIn of course uses suggestions and
recommendations systems to determine who
we should connect with and who is maybe
most similar to us and common networking
both in person and online follows our
social circles how we deal with money
and how we're evaluated with money also
is affected by these doors whether we
can get a small business loan or a home
loan is often based on some sort of
metric we're evaluated and determined
whether we are credit worthy
peer-to-peer lending usually uses these
social network circles to determine what
type of people we might want to lend to
or be recipients of universities on our
schooling how we find out about new
career opportunities to grow and learn
more are also affected by these
algorithms and often these university
applications for example go down to a
series of metrics based on standardized
test scores and finally social media
dating sites even and the recommendation
algorithms that feed us the news that we
read and what we decide to like on
whatever social network we are on all of
those take into account these signals
that we send whether the signal is I'm
going to ignore this person I'm going to
swipe right whatever it is the signals
are things that feed algorithms that
determine what we see and as many
studies have shown in the past year
there is those can even affect elections
so depending on what news we have and
the so called bubbles that were in then
we can get into the feedback loop where
we're surrounded by people who think
like us so when we live in a world that
is very unjust now while Elsa da we a
famous feminist and radical from Egypt
tells us that we must be dissidents when
I see this quote I wonder what does it
actually mean to be a dissident here
can't I just do my work can't I just be
a data scientist and I'm a good person
I'm trying to do the right thing isn't
that enough and I think that she would
advise us that perhaps we can take it
one step further that just being a good
person
doesn't necessarily mean that we're
pushing things forward that we're really
challenging the industry to do things
potentially differently I would hope
that by the end of this talk we can
maybe agree that there are certain steps
that we can take so that we're more
accountable and moving forward with
ethical machine-learning finally there
was an article a few months ago by
Michael on Carole and he called it
ethics cannot be a side hustle he was
writing towards a design audience and he
used the uber gray ball application how
many people here have heard of uber gray
ball so it's this application and it's
served to what they call flagged writers
these are usually people that are
government inspectors there are people
that are trying to crack down on uber
that uber is illegal
wherever the jurisdiction is and they're
trying to find and find the writers and
the drivers as well so they developed
this application called gray ball that
serves them a fake app experience they
look like they're using uber what
they're not
and Mike's argument was that you cannot
build something as unethical as this
during the work week and then on the
weekends by your ethical offsets by
donating your time to social good
I would agree with this sentiment I
think that most everybody in this room
has data skills and could probably find
a job tomorrow if you wanted to so if
you're asked to do something unethical
at work or if you feel like you might be
working for an ethical company then I
put the onus on you to make the decision
to make a move and make a statement by
putting your work behind somebody you
can believe in so how do these things
come to happen we have this world our
world has in Justices and then all the
sudden they're in our algorithms so I'm
going to take you through a bit of a
story I believe that with most stories
around data science it starts with the
data itself so we're in this world of
quote-unquote big data whether you
believe it or not it is around us and
particularly if you do machine learning
you've probably been expose the idea
that larger data sets generally
generalize better that they are more
useful and that particularly if you're
doing neural networks or deep learning
that you benefit from having the extra
data that your model learns better and
is better applied to real word situate
situations or perhaps data that it
hasn't seen before so if this big data
is great for us then what might be
lurking underneath crowd-sourced data it
has been really revolutionary especially
in some of the NLP tasks when we're able
to use crowdsource data for things like
sentiment analysis or even image
captioning then we can see much better
results because we have a lot of
different data and different
perspectives about the same image or the
same tweet and so forth so crowdsourcing
has been really pushing the envelope
forward and when it comes to certain NLP
tasks this is an image from the Flickr
30k data set and a PhD student here in
Amsterdam Emil van miltenberg sorry if I
pronounced that wrong he's a student at
the view Amsterdam and he took a look at
this Flickr 30k data set and he was able
to find both gender and racial
stereotypes well
in the captions one of the top-rated
captions of this image is a worker is
being scolded by her boss in a stern
lecture we can see that the automatic
assumption of this image is that the
woman is the worker and the man is her
boss we can also see that the automatic
assumption is that she has done
something wrong and is being reprimanded
another caption for it is a hot blonde
girl getting criticized by her boss so
if we needed even more encoding we can
see that women will be categorized by
their physical features and the man is
again assumed to be her boss what he
found even beyond this is that anybody
in the data set who looked even
particularly asian was immediately
classified as Japanese or Chinese and
anybody who looks dark-skinned was
immediately classified as
african-american even if there was no
signal in the photo that they were in
America or that the person was American
so we can see that we sneaked into our
data sets we need crowdsourcing because
it helps us give those larger datasets
and it helps us achieve things with
these NLP tasks but at the same time
Emile points out in a further article
that perhaps we are training our models
not only to view the world from an
American mindset but possibly also a
white American mindset I think that
another thing that we need to think
about in regards to our data is whether
it was sourced ethically now if you're
the type of person that would actively
source your clothing or ethically source
your food then why would you not
ethically source your data I think that
one unfortunate part of this is we do
not have a good way to be conscious
consumers of data a lot of times the way
that it was collected and how it was
collected is somewhat obscure for us so
the more that we can push to have the
data provenance
to have the way that it was collected to
have the information about how these
customers consented to their data being
shared the more that we can determine
whether it was ethically sourced and
really push on having that data be
collected the proper way I would argue
that data privacy privacy has become a
privilege in our world that it's no
longer a right and that because of the
way that we've capitalized data that it
reflects some of the forms of capitalism
in our world one of the ways as this is
done is by offering free services
exchange for deities so for example
Facebook it will offer free Wi-Fi if you
check in they do so so that they can
collect the check-in data and then use
the check-in data to sell advertisements
now how many other forms are similar to
this and how many other surveys or
chance to win also do the same
collection of data too often we are kind
of collecting data after the at the
behest of whoever the end user is rather
than thinking about the actual customer
or the client that we're collecting the
data from and within our data set we're
not asking often how exactly they were
collected also another privilege is
technological literacy so within this
room or fairly technologically literate
we're aware of being able to use VPNs
and tor and using incognito sessions and
so forth to protect our data browsing
history we are also aware when we see
weird forms online perhaps to back away
and not tell them out this is one
example from four mismo and it
essentially is an opt-out form and what
they did when they did Studies on this
is something between 60 and 70% of
people would just click the default
options so they would never uncheck
boxes or check extra boxes so when data
is collected this way or perhaps even
survey data is collected this way we
have to ask ourselves does the end
consumer actually know that their data
might be so
to third parties do they know that their
data might be used for some other
purpose when they're browsing around
online and they don't remember to delete
their cookies do they know that they're
getting a different price do they know
that their data is being collected and
used to serve them different
advertisements I would say that the
average Internet user probably doesn't
know these things and that perhaps we
should think about how to better signal
for them
thankfully the EU has put in some great
data privacy regulations but they're
constantly being challenged in the
courts and sometimes our data comes from
outside the EU so we need to be
cognizant when we make those decisions
ondrea's do this gave a great talk
at 32 C 3 the Chaos Computer Club
conference and what he was able to show
and he released his Python code I'll
have links to all of these things in a
post up end but what he was able to show
with a linear SVM is that the more data
that he gauged the model the better it
was able to discriminate amongst groups
he had created some artificial data that
had certain differential characteristics
between two different groups and the
more data he said it the better it was
able to discriminate now that's great
for us as data scientists in a sense of
hey it's learning and is doing well with
discrimination right if that's the task
that we're looking for then we're doing
quite well but will we have to ask as
ethical data scientists and to take a
step back and say how much data do we
actually need and how much accuracy do
we actually need is it always better to
use more data and have higher accuracy
even if the data that we're using is
perhaps less ethically sourced or
perhaps adding in some of these
unintended correlations
so often we find that these data sources
find their way into our models if we're
doing our job right then our models
reflect the real world and if they
reflect the real world and the real
world has in Justices then our models
therefore reflect these real injustice
and just in Justices now that might be
fine depending on what you're doing
whatever you're doing might have very
little impact or just be used internally
we have to really think about does that
bleed into other areas and does this
impact people's lives and livelihoods
one easy way to see if the biases are
coming through is by looking at natural
language because we can look at language
and we can make interpretations on the
meaning of the words or the phrases and
one great way to do that within data
science is to use word vectors so there
was a great study by Eileen calisca in
Islam along with two really prominent
ethical machine learning specialists
Joanna Bryson and Arvind Narayan on and
they did a study on word vectors they
used gloves but I feel like you could
easily do with word direct and it would
give you the same results and what they
were able to show is that language
inherits these cultural biases and they
did so in numerous ways but one of the
ways that was really prominent was the
ways that gender was reflected in
profession that often the jobs that were
more gendered towards women we're easily
you could see the shift of the word
vector to correlate women with the
female centric jobs and men would male
centered jobs so one really easy way to
show this is to simply use Google
Translate in Google Translate you can
take a gendered language like English or
German or whatever you'd like and you
could translate into a non gendered
language Turkish is a non gendered
language so we can take a phrase she's a
professor and he's a babysitter and we
can put them from English into Turkish
when we click simply to reverse
translate all of a sudden he becomes a
professor and she is the babysitter and
this is again Google is not doing
anything evil the Translate app is not
written by a bunch of a bunch of sexist
monsters this is simply in the word
vectors themselves the word vectors have
learned these relationships they've done
what we asked them to do they learned
the fact that in our data that we feed
it it has these biases we know that more
men are professors and more women are
babysitters and so these language biases
come through in the data they're learned
in a language in the way that we talk
about it and then they pop up in Google
Translate another great example and data
said that I was impressed by how quickly
it could turn a inequality into a metric
was the ProPublica study on compass now
compass is a recidivism risk evaluation
system and what it does is it attempts
to guess how likely it is that you'll go
back to jail or prison once you've been
let out of jail or prison so it's used
in several jurisdictions within the
United States to determine along with
other metrics whether a person should be
left out on early parole and so forth
the ProPublica study said this this
machine learning algorithm this
algorithm this software is racially
biased and they showed this chart which
is a distribution chart and on the Left
there's the different scores for the
black defendants going from the left to
the right it goes to the increased risk
and from the white defendants scores
they are on the right-hand side and you
can see that there there's a majority
distribution towards the lower decile
scores
however a dong a data scientist in San
Francisco took another look at the data
and he took instead a look at the
conditional effects and here sorry the
song is a bit low is a bit small but the
probability of recidivism is on the y
axis and then the scores are along the x
axis and what we can actually see here
is the dots are fairly close together so
the algorithm or the software in and of
itself is not biased in fact we see that
some of the blue dots which represent
the white population actually have lower
probability for a higher score now what
does this tell us how can we see a
distribution like before and yet still
see that the algorithm in and of itself
is in fact skewing probability towards
in favor of the black offenders what it
tells us is maybe this metric is not so
much measuring recidivism but instead is
measuring the policing tactics of
certainly officers in the United States
and if the policing tactic is that I am
more likely to pursue arrests and really
challenge a black defendant versus a
white defendant then this can explain
what's happening so I think that we like
metrics we like numbers they make sense
they measure things for us and I think
often they're useful but if we forget
what the metric is actually measuring
then it's really easy to get confused
and to just kind of fall asleep at the
wheel and let the numbers and metrics
take hold of our algorithms so if it's
really easy to have these types of
insidious things in our data and then
it's really easy for that data to learn
them and display them in algorithms then
how can we actually test for this unfair
treatment how do we test for what I
would sometimes refer to as embedded
isms this is different sexism racism
homophobia transphobia other things like
that in our model
if we can't test for them then we
probably don't know that they're there
and if we don't test for them then
they're likely there and we're just
ignoring them one way that this can be
tested is by looking at disparate impact
and what disparate impact looks at is it
looks at two different groups and a
particular outcome so let's say Smurfs
and non Smurfs and they are going for
loans and they would like to get the
loans now we can determine disparate
impact if we can show the probability of
a Smurfs getting alone is very higher
than a probability of a non Smurf
getting a loan and if we can show that
it's above a certain Delta then we can
say yes this has a disparate impact this
is overly affecting the non Smurfs and
they are being treated unfairly this is
used in several court cases but it also
is a great measurement just within our
own data sets to determine again this
however requires kind of almost a binary
outcome and not every problem has a
binary outcome one such example is using
word embeddings so again ilene pelican
and her co researchers developed two
different tests to test word embeddings
they're called the word embedding
Association test and the word embedding
factual Association test and it
essentially is based on a psychological
study and this psychological study
allows you to correlate words with one
another and it measures the correlation
by how quickly you're able to correlate
and raise your hand or press button to
say yes that relates to that this test
usually starts out with easy things like
flowers are Pleasant and insects are
unpleasant I would argue with that I
quite like today insects insects but
this is a test that works fairly well in
psychology
what they did to model eight amongst
their word vectors is they took cosine
similarity and then they took the
probability of that cosine similarity
over all of the different vectors and
they were able to show some interesting
and also quite a key relationships
within the vectors that they trained for
example in the german word vectors they
were able to find pleasant or positive
relationships between German nationality
words and the German vectors and
unpleasant relationships between Turkish
nationality words and the German word
vectors so this is great if you're
dealing with word vector data I highly
encourage you to take a read of the
paper and perhaps apply some of the
tests yourself so if you're not dealing
with NLP data and you're not dealing and
you're not dealing with a binary outcome
situation how do you determine that
there is unfairness in your data set
well another great paper and also a
Python library that you can install is
called fair test and what fair tests
tried to measure is unwarranted
associations in the data so a lot of
times we can find that gender or race is
encoded in other features so maybe
gender is also encoded in first name or
maybe race is also encoded in zip code
or possibly last name and when we start
to take a look at the way that the the
model starts to correlate these two
things even if we remove the variables
that we don't want it to learn and it
still determines that these signals are
happening in other parts of our data
fair test is a great way to try and find
these relationships and they have both
ways that you can take a look at
particular features again this is for
tagged features but they also have ways
that you can have it run discovery and
try to find some features for you that
may be correlated to the variables that
you would like not to have inserted into
your data set
so if we can test and we can find that
we have unfair treatment or perhaps we
are already running something in
production and we find that there is
this unfair treatment how can we figure
out how to combat this unfair treatment
how can we remove it without sacrificing
our models right we still want great
models we still want good predictions or
suggestions or classifications and so
forth so how can we use these broken
data sets and broken models to a certain
degree and fix them ethically while
still having good accuracy and so forth
one possible way which was presented by
M&S Tola who's a lead machine learning
researcher at meetup comm is to use
ensemble models he gave a great talk at
machine learning Seattle I believe
called win recommendation systems go bad
and what he and the meetup team noticed
is their recommendation algorithm had
learned how to a correlate gender with
interest and was doing things like
suggesting more technology meetups to
men than women because it had learned
more men attend technology meetups than
women what they didn't want is this
reinforcing the status quo of the
industry and so what they decided to do
is to segregate their data to have one
model that is aware of gender along with
a few other data sets to have another
model that's aware of interests and
therefore the models were not able to
have these unwanted learning
associations then they use an ensemble
model at the end and if they get the
benefits of all of the different data
sets but the models themselves are
unaware of the other data connections
perhaps another way to fight it is to
take a look at misses again with
somewhat of a binary outcome situation
at equal odds and equal opportunity so
there was a great paper that was
released near the end of last year call
the equality of opportunity in
supervised learning I highly recommend
taking read and they also released an
interactive that you can play with and
see online and I'll read just a few
excerpts from the paper because I feel
like there are quite important equalized
odds enforces that the accuracy is
equally high in all demographics
punishing models that perform well
only on the majority so this is
essentially asking us to pin our true
positives and true negative rates for
our models across different demographic
groups that's kind of a high task so
they also released a possible relaxation
which they called equal opportunity so
this possible relaxation of equalized
odds is to require non-discrimination
only within the advantage outcome group
that is to require that people who pay
back their loan have an equal
opportunity of getting one in the first
place so this is instead appending the
only the true positive rates to one
another but one thing that this helps
protect against is just that our modern
model performs well for the majority use
case and often that's what we do
but when we take a look at how it might
affect minority groups within our data
set or different demographic groups then
using this equal opportunity helps us
ensure that we're treating people fairly
or at least more fairly and assuming
everybody conforms to the majority group
finally we need to create transparent
and explainable models this was a
constant refrain across nearly all of my
research that the less were able to
introspect and explain our models the
less were able to figure out what
they've learned and if they've learned
something that we don't want them to
learn and we can't see or explain them
then it's unlikely that we can then
combats them I was having a great
discussion with my PI data Berlin
co-organizer of Mattie Lyra and he's an
NLP
right and we were discussing the dangers
of the fact that we're seeing more and
more of these machine learning as a
service providers come around and I
think that that's really great I don't
think that you should have to have a
machine learning expert to do machine
learning but the danger I feel like that
we border in those moments is that the
end user do they actually know what's
happening in the model do they actually
know what they're using machine learning
for do they know what data they should
keep out or do they know if their data
is perhaps acting unethically this is a
really big problem and if you work at a
start-up that does machine learning as a
service you need to really think about
how you communicate to the end-user what
is happening there was a great article
on building more clear and explainable
models called ideas on interpreting
machine learning those by the h2o AIT
one of the examples out of many that
they gave again I highly recommend
reading it is the idea of using maximum
activation analysis to take a look at
your neural network what this allows you
to do and we've seen this a lot in the
computer vision is kind of inspect what
nodes are learning what attributes so
we've seen this a lot in computer vision
or perhaps all this style transfer oh
this one is this node is learning this
particular part of face recognition or
this node is learning this particular
part of Van Gogh's style and so forth
but when we have non visual data how do
we inspect one way to do so is to build
and generate fake data that can show us
the maximum activation if we build this
fake data and we notice that we some of
the nodes are starting to learn
attributes that we don't want it to
learn then we can figure out perhaps how
to down weight or remove those
activations so perhaps here we have the
real customer and we have the bad guy
and we see they're activating different
nodes and then we may notice over time
that there is some overlap between our
real customers and the bad guy even
so they don't represent what we want the
model to learn so I hate to put ethics
and Wall Street in the same sentence so
I really considered taking this out but
but I think it really is great so even
though ethics in Wall Street don't
normally go together Emanuel Derman and
Paul Wilmot
are to financial modelers researchers
and authors around kind of the quant
space so to speak and after the
financial crisis of 2008 they took a
step back and they wrote this thing they
called the financial modelers manifesto
and it's kind of like the communist
manifesto for financial modelers and
even though not all this work in concert
with financial products I still think
that we can take a lot from this
manifesto it is indeed what they called
in Hippocratic oath for modelers and I
do think that there's something to be
said for having an ethical Creed for us
as data scientists and this machine the
learning experts sort of speak or
implementers at least they'll go through
it and we can see how much of it applies
to our work I will remember that I
didn't make the world and it doesn't
satisfy my equations though I will use
models boldly to estimate value I will
not be overly impressed by mathematics
I will never sacrifice reality for
elegance without explaining why I have
done so nor will I give people who use
my model false comfort about its
accuracy instead I will make explicit it
assumptions and oversights and finally I
understand that my work may have
enormous effects on society and the
economy many of them beyond my
comprehension
again I don't think every one of these
applies to all of the work that we do
but I do think the idea of humility the
idea of clarity the idea of indifference
to fancy math and doing things the most
clever way is perhaps something that we
can take away and maybe we can use
something like this Creed as a starting
point for creating a more ethical way to
do machine learning and data science in
the projects and the work that we do
already today so I want to end with a
quote by another pretty awesome lady
this is rosalind Franklin who helped
discover DNA and she said that science
and everyday life cannot and should not
be separated what I think that she mean
and what I take away from this is that
they're inherently intertwined right a
lot of the work that we do we get the
data from everyday life and we're
building products and trying to effect
change also in everyday life so we can't
pull them apart and if the everyday life
of our world reflects injustice then our
models of course do so - what I
challenge us to do is to not be a
feedback loop that is spouting more
inequalities and more injustice into the
world that the feedback loop is already
here that I challenge us to actually try
to put less inequality in the world and
build more fair and more equitable
models than already exist if we take
into account that we apply some of the
things that I've covered in this talk
and we build and continue to challenge
more things that allow us to create
ethical or more ethical machine learning
products then I think that our models
can actually help fight injustice in the
world and that we can be a dissident as
in a while Elsa dolly would call us
so I challenge you not to just be great
data scientists and great machine
learning specialists I challenge you to
be great and ethical machine learning
specialists and data scientist and I
think that we as a community can do so
we can do better thanks
[Applause]